le temps retour au verglas cette nuit
toute l'europe à froid pologne le
général jamais ce qu'ils rencontrent le
primat de pologne d'état ciel semble
s'assoupir coup de filet en italie l'un
des cerveaux des brigades rouges arrêter
là monsieur bonsoir une certaine tiédeur
après le froide hier en tout cas au nord
et à l'ouest du pays
il a fait moins froid aujourd'hui et si
l'alsace reste verglacée si le verglas
menace de revenir ce soir nous sommes
plus privilégiés que nos voisins
européens
chez les britanniques qui sont si
friands de records en tout genre
il n'a jamais fait aussi froid depuis
1895 françois cornet et ce train
immobilisé au pays de galles illustre
parfaitement la situation
les troupes héliportées au secours des
voyageurs du chemin de fer ce n'est
évidemment pas un spectacle courant mais
il faut savoir que la grande-bretagne
registre actuellement effectivement des
températures de moins 30 degrés on
n'avait pas grelotter autant depuis un
siècle le royaume uni ont fait même du
ski à brighton à 60 km de londres et
l'opposition travailliste a réclamé la
création d'un ministère du mauvais temps
pour organiser coordonner l'acheminement
des secours aux habitants et au bétail
de nombreux villages isolés par la neige
et aux centaines d'automobilistes
bloqués sur les routes
intempéries également en allemagne de
nous parviennent ces images
d'inondations tourné à düsseldorf
aujourd'hui le rhin a paralysé la ville
un peu plus haut en europe du nord on
enregistrait la nuit dernière et
aujourd'hui au danemark ou en norvège
des températures de moins 50 degrés un
temps à ne vraiment pas laisser dehors
une petite sirène en france la situation
n'est pas confortable que dans les
départements où les inondations sont
toujours menaçante comme dans la nièvre
et en aquitaine dans d'autres
départements où l'on craint les crues
les autorités et la population tente de
mettre sur pied un dispositif préventif
comme dans ce petit village près de
montargis éric pelletier châteaurenard
près de montargis 17
toute la population est en état d'
alerte luan la petite rivière qui
traverse le pays a déjà inondé plusieurs
villages en amont alors il faut prendre
ces compte de cela les salles et vos
meubles
oui donc à l eau arrive la prochaine
samantha la caractérielle et que
savait-il en déçoit
chacun connaît ici les caprices de lohan
pour la surveille on mesure la montée
inexorable
la côte d'alerté déjà atteint qui peu à
peu des centaines d'hectares vont
disparaître sous un lac d'eau et de boue
on peut au moins essayer des mitaines
kenya imaginez alors mieux vaut mieux
prévoir de plus que pas du tout une fois
de plus les pompiers bénévoles sont
mises à contribution
depuis ce matin ils font le sorte à fort
de la solidarité
moi
m
bon
les personnages et on a obligé de passer
par tous alors depuis depuis 13h ce
travail là et puis il ya ceux qui se
débrouillent seuls avec les moyens du
bord
luan déborde assez souvent ils ont
l'habitude
17h30 le danger se précise un peu ça
monte vite là
je vous ai vu qu mais de combien de
combien depuis 78 la dernière fois c'est
un surhomme 18 équivalent depuis cinq
ans
les flèches de plus en plus de talent
sa valeur
au bas du corps
donc continuer à monter comme d'habitude
il y a ceux qui n'ont rien prévu et
retrouveront leur voiture noyer demain
matin alors qu'il est le village de
châteaurenard et inondé en
ille-et-vilaine l'hôpital de vitré a été
partiellement évacué ce matin par
précaution devant la crue de ville
si les rigueurs de l'hiver sont parfois
dangereuses et désagréable on oublie
trop souvent que ce sont surtout les
enfants qui en font les frais ces
millions d'enfants qui tous les matins
dans les campagnes ont de longs trajets
à faire avant d'arriver à l'école
l'enquète de lorraine cusin
florence 15 ans est debout à 6 heures
elle rentrera à 19 heures le lycée à 35
kilomètres de son village
tous les matins un quart d'heure de
marche jusqu'à l'arrêt d'autobus
puis une heure et demie de trajet même
chose le soir
presque quatre heures en tout cette
nuit-là neigé ce sera encore plus long
je commence à vraiment marre
quand on pense qu'un enfant est parti
plus de douze heures de chez lui subir
qu'un adulte il peut pas avoir le soir
une vigneronne
ce n'est pas possible il ne vais pas
bien travaillé ce n'est pas possible et
il ne peut que se coucher à des heures
indues et encore le samedi et le
dimanche il faut travailler il ne peut
plus s'adonner à des supports l'avoir
des activités de loisirs
il y à une partie de sa jeunesse
d'après les textes le trajet les retours
ne doit pas excéder une heure et demie
par jour en tout mais qui se soucie
d'appliquer les textes on utilise des
cartes trop grand alors on les remplit
où les rentabilise quitte à tracer des
itinéraires invraisemblable impossible
de créer d'autres circuits
l'entreprise de transport à un monopole
de fait sur la région ya pâtes seront
sur pied meilleure étape je pense y
avait une concurrence on arrivera
peut-être à obtenir un m
les conditions de transport meilleur des
prix peut être encore plus appréciable
pour les communes
et puis la bête noire des parents la
sécurité bien sûr il n'y a pas que tant
d'accidents que cela sur les deux
millions d'enfants transporter cinq
morts l'an dernier mais on calcule
toujours au plus juste peu d'abri sur
les routes circulation mal réglementée
aux abords des écoles
car surchargé 25% des véhicules sont en
mauvais état certains ouvrir plus de 12
ans et surtout absence quasi-totale de
surveillance à bord quel que soit l'âge
des enfants on va conduire et est ce que
fait de suspens car on sait que bien le
petit peu mais le rétroviseur
impossible de payer un surveillant pour
les 30000 circuits existants dit on au
ministère
le coût du carburant absorbe presque
tout le budget
les enfants ne doivent absolument pas
supporter les conséquences d'un budget
restreint et surtout quand il s'agit de
choses aussi graves que d' accidents de
la circulation
c'est impossible de raisonner comme ça
depuis dix ans 3000 écoles rurales ont
été fermés l'implantation des lycées se
décide encore de paris la moitié des
élèves en france ne vit pas assez près
de l'école pour y aller à pied
le car est donc devenu le prolongement
naturel de l'école or il n'y a pas de
réelle politique des transports
scolaires et pour un service public qui
concerne des enfants
on parle encore de ramassage
samedi laborieux pour plusieurs
ministres du gouvernement si c'est
exactement qui se sont retrouvés
aujourd'hui à bordeaux
parmi eux gaston defferre jacques delors
et edith cresson
le but de cette journée girondine
rencontrer les élus du conseil régional
d'aquitaine les employés de la sias des
chefs d'entreprise des agriculteurs et
des syndicalistes résultats concrets la
signature d'un certain nombre de
contrats de solidarité destiné à créer
des emplois dans la région
cet après midi quelques 15 cents
agriculteurs ont manifesté leur
mécontentement contre la politique
gouvernementale dans les rues de
bordeaux
en pologne le régime accélère le rythme
de la normalisation tandis qu en europe
les sympathisants de solidarité
multiplie les efforts pour que
l'indifférence ne soit pas le linceul de
la crise polonaise ainsi ses immenses
affiches dans les regards vous fixe dans
les rues des grandes villes françaises
à l'initiative d'un groupe de
publicitaires et d'activistes de droits
de l'homme qui ne veulent pas que l'on
oublie la pologne
plusieurs nouvelle importante en
provenance de varsovie aujourd'hui le
général jarre usines ce qui a rencontré
le primat de pologne qui après quatre
semaines d'état de siège a donc
finalement accepté de le voir et puis la
censure contre les journalistes
étrangers a été officiellement levé
aujourd'hui autant de signes d'un
certain assouplissement de l'état de
siège
oui il semble qu'un mois après l'état de
siège la double impasse intérieur et
extérieur dans lequel le régime
militaire nouveau était arrivé amen
apparemment le jeune âge arroser le ski
et le conseil militaire de salut
national
un petit peu desserré l'étreinte et
effectivement la rencontre cet après
midi entre le primat de pologne et le
président du conseil militaire est très
importante
bien que l'on ne sache pas trop ce qui
s'y est dit le communiqué qui a été dit
à la radio et à la télévision polonaise
parle simplement d'un échange de vues
sur la situation du pays est
l'expression d'intention sur un retour à
la vie normale dans le pays alors il
faut attendre d'en savoir un petit peu
plus mais c'est quand même quelque chose
effectivement de très important parce
que jusqu'ici monsigna dlep refusait de
rencontrer général josette c'qui les
conditions que pose l'église à un
véritable engagement un véritable
dialogue c'est vous le savez d'une part
la libération des internés et des
personnes arrêtées depuis le coup d'état
et d'autre part en particulier que lech
walesa soit mis sous sa protection et on
peut imaginer que monseigneur glem pas
prêt surtout les mails velits
fracassante qui l'a fait l'occasion de
l'épiphanie a dû rappeler ça au général
jacques osele ce qui au même moment le
parti ouvrier polonais semble en train
de procéder à une formidable purge
intérieure pour retrouver une forme de
crédibilité
oui effectivement là il y à 2 2 de geste
qui me semble important le premier celle
annonce pour le 20 janvier d'une réunion
de la diète c'est à dire le parlement
polonais qui sera amené à près un grand
discours ou que l'on attend du général
jaruzelski à prendre des décisions
nouvelles concernant l'avenir du pays
car tout laisse à penser qu'on va
essayer de revenir peut-être à une
constitutionnalité si j'ose dire un peu
plus importante
et puis d'autre part depuis quelques
jours on est frappé d'entendre qu'il y à
des réunions dans tous les provinces des
membres du parti et que l'on assiste à
une renaissance en quelque sorte de ce
parti ouvrier sur une ligne
pure et dure un certain nombre
d'exclusions de hauts dirigeants
notamment les dirigeants de katowice et
monsieur fischbach dow jones qui était
l'un des signataires des accords de
gdansk ont été annoncés et on a
l'impression que là il va y avoir un
renouveau au sein de ce parti sur une
base effectivement je crois très dur et
en tout cas on annonce que tous les gens
qui ont eu des responsabilités dans la
crise seront écartés la pologne a dominé
ce matin la longue audience que jean
paul ii a accordé aux ministres français
des relations extérieures claude
cheysson c'était le premier contact
entre le souverain pontife est un membre
du gouvernement socialiste français de
rome victor vraiment c'était la première
fois qu'un membre du gouvernement
socialiste a été reçue par jean paul ii
au vatican
l'entretien prévu de longue date devait
durer 30 minutes il a duré une heure
c'est que jean paul ii est intarissable
lorsqu'il s'agit de la liberté
religieuse des droits de l'homme de la
révolte de l'homme contre les systèmes
totalitaires
c'est à dire quand il s'agit de la
pologne de sa pologne natale
je dois dire que moi responsable
français j'écoutais j'étais aux aguets
pour comprendre ce que le pape sait que
les paniers et que nous ne savons pas au
mieux guider notre action mais qui était
très frappant ce matin et quand il s'est
agi 0 de l'homme la personnalité de
l'homme en face de la machine n'a pas
des structures
j'ai pu apporter au souverain pontife
l'assurance que le peuple français
réagissait comme comme il l'espérait
mais est-ce que vous avez l'impression
que le vatican est en mesure où mène
actuellement une action concrète en
faveur peut-être des membres de
solidarité où ils ont fait ce que le
vatican essaie de faire quelque chose en
pologne n'apprendrez rien en disant que
le vatican l'envoyé du souverain pontife
à varsovie conscient poggi récemment ont
demandé aux autorités polonaises ont
presque exigé des autorités polonaises
qu'un certain nombre de conditions
soient satisfaites immédiatement à lever
l'état de siège
la libération des internés
la reprise du dialogue tout cela est
bien connu ceci dit on ne peut pas
comparer l'action du vatican et l'action
d'un gouvernement après qu'un bon film
mais diable le chef de l'église à vision
infiniment plus longue en italie
le problème majeur reste le terrorisme
le regain de vitalité des brigades
rouges illustré par l'enlèvement du
général américain d'osier accuse
maintenant le gouvernement à prendre les
grands moyens
l'armée pourrait être appelé à
participer à la lutte antiterroriste
joli coup de filet à l'actif de la
police
aujourd'hui à rome le préfet de police a
annoncé l'arrestation de l'un des
cerveaux des brigades rouges philippe
chatenet une opération éclair déclenchée
ce matin par la police romaine aurait
permis l'arrestation de nombreux
terroristes présumés dont huit membres
des brigades rouges et surtout d'un des
cerveaux de la direction suprême des
brigades depuis l'enlèvement le 17
décembre dernier du général américain
james d'osier les brigades rouges sont
plus que jamais la cible prioritaire des
forces anti-terroristes italienne ces
images tournées discrètement par la
télévision italienne montre les lieux de
l'arrestation ce matin du professeur
giovanni sénat ni arrestation qui
devrait être confirmée d'un instant à
l'autre de source policière officiel
giovanni ciserani 42 ans professeur de
criminologie que l'on voit ici dans une
interview de 1979 était passée dans la
clandestinité peu après deux venant
selon la police l'un des membres de la
direction stratégique des brigades
rouges
son arrestation est l'un des plus l'une
des plus importantes jamais réussi dans
la commune contre le terrorisme et vient
un moment important
les efforts de la police pour retrouver
le général d'osier restent vaines des
informations selon lesquelles ils
seraient détenus dans les abruzzes ont
donné lieu à d'importantes opérations
tout sans résultat un nouveau message
attribué aux brigades rouges le
quatrième depuis l'enlèvement est
parvenue aux autorités hier soir mais ne
contient semble-t-il aucun élément
nouveau
enfin le gouvernement italien a décidé
de renforcer la lutte contre le
terrorisme en particulier en utilisant
certains éléments de l'armée et en
adoptant un plan pour combattre
l'infiltration des groupes armés au sein
des syndicats et des usines
l'état italien ne lésine pas sur les
honneurs pour la première fois une femme
vient d'être nommé sénateur à vie
il faut dire qu'elle a déjà 93 ans il
s'agit de madame ravera l'une des
fondatrices du parti communiste italien
l'histoire du jour est une histoire de
faux non pas de faux tableaux mais
defour mené tout le monde pensait à
nantes que jean monnet était bien le
petit fils de son grand-père le maître
des nymphéas le grand peintre claude
monet
la réalité était tout autre gail montluc
il ressemble à claude monet s'intéresse
à la peinture prétend s'appeler jean
monnet mais ce n'est pas le petit fils
du grand peintre
en fait c'est un artiste en escroquerie
arrivé à nantes en 77 il a tout pour
plaire la silhouette bohème un nom
prestigieux
il sera de toutes les réceptions fait
citoyen d'honneur passant pour un
octogénaire ils conquirent l'affection
d'une famille qui aujourd'hui s'en mord
les doigts de l'adopter comme grand père
les enfants très heureux nous se
regarder et lui ont répondu oui et puis
ça s'est fait comme ça il y a un an il
disparaît avec 42 mille francs la
famille s'inquiète elle a tort
cet homme s'appelle en réalité joseph
munier il a 20 ans de moins qu il ne
paraît il est recherché par interpol et
a déjà séjourné en prison
et puis sous cette barbe blanche se
cachait un ancien de la waffen ss
condamné à mort par contumace
les noms tête n'en reviennent pas
d'autant qu'ils avaient promis monts et
merveilles à certains nous ça nous a
fait énormément de mal quand on a appris
que dresse alors là j'en ai souffert
mois pendant la guerre aussi et je vous
dis franchement que cesse ça fait mal
nous avons mal souffert beaucoup de gens
souffrent encore devant les enfants
maintenant ils veulent plus en parler
ils veulent pas qu'on ne vend pas c'est
normal parce qu'il avait beaucoup
d'affection humaines pour lui vous avez
de la rancune contre ce personnage de la
rancune je peux pas dire même que je lui
en veux si on est on éprouve quand même
une certaine rancune mais enfin j'ai pas
pensé cette chose là c'est tout la mort
du cheval et du jeu amène tous les jours
à vincennes un flot de turfiste un peu
plus acharnés que les autres car ce ne
sont pas nécessairement les plus riches
qui nourrissent malgré la crise
l'accroissement annuel des recettes du
pari mutuel carré de brest
les histoires le disait didier
prophétise non nous ne sommes pas autour
de la corbeille de la bourse de paris
mais dans le hall public de l'hippodrome
de vincennes le dialogue en code chiffré
de ces hommes correspond à une étude
approfondie du programme des courses de
l'après midi pour les turfiste cet
investissement est aussi sérieux que le
choix d'un portefeuille d'actions en
bourse
mais ici il faut payer cash pour un
placement à très court terme est le plus
souvent un fonds perdus c'est une
passion les bourses et sa mamie ça me
passe le temps seulement il faut réunir
et joué dans une seule course d'après
s'arrêter qu'on perde et alors mais
évidemment comme tout le monde
oh je joue à peu près maximum maximum 60
fondant la réunion et pourquoi vous
jouez au cours c'est beaucoup découvrir
pour me distraire
parce que prendrait j'étais enfermé
toute ma vie dans un bureau ou dans un
autre métier je veux sortir jouer en
vert
le public le plus mélanger sans
distinction d'âge ou de niveau social
partagent la même passion dévorante pour
les secours de course car aussi
paradoxal que cela puisse paraître
l'argent n'est pas la seule motivation
des turfistes
à l'époque
allez
gagner souvent ça va nous aider à gagner
au cou non c'est pas facile où on les
suit on les suit pas toujours
oui pratique moi c'est votre métier non
je vous remettiez ce bon dérivatif
j'adore ça au lieu d'aller au cinéma
tout va bien on cause je suis
représentant je travaillais comme ça
comme ça chaque fois je tourne je gagne
ou on gagne jamais j'en prenais un
maximum et nous on vient parce que ça
nous disent très discret ces souris
trahi
bien sûr que je travaille mon boulot les
tonnages alors vous jouez le chômage
alors non je pense aux images avant j'ai
pas dans le besoin de passer un produit
c'est un peu difficile en fin de l'année
on arrête alors pourquoi nous devons
continuer là n'est pas parce que on a
toujours envie de gagner et de gagner
grosses fortunes et de s'arrêter un jour
mais comment on gagnerait jamais l art
continuera toujours
en fait
y compris à ce jeu l'état est le seul
vrai gagnant cet impôt volontaire qui
atteint près de 20 milliards de francs
loup 1980 a rapporté plus de 3 milliards
aux finances publiques en amoureux
inconditionnel des courses les joueurs
pardonne toutes les trahisons du hasard
ou des chevaux et pour quelques pièces
rachète aussitôt une part de rêve
ce sont les parieurs qui font vivre les
courses et l'élevage
malgré cela l'institution des courses ne
parvient plus à supporter les
prélèvements de toutes sortes
alors entre autres solutions pour créer
une nouvelle recette on a institué un
troisième tiers celle de madère je joue
très peu 40 50 francs par course et
quand je gagne je double émises et il ya
d'autres joueurs qui font le contraire
mais le fait de venir avec 200 ou 300
francs peut passer une bonne après-midi
mais la grande majorité des tur fils ne
possède malheureusement pas la science
d'un technicien du hasard finalement
leur destin est de ramasser les miettes
il ya sûrement quelques heureux avec les
résultats du tiercé de vincennes
aujourd'hui il fallait jouer le 14 le 5
et le 9 les rapports pour 5 francs dans
l'ordre 3335 francs dans un ordre
différent 700 et 7 francs et puis il y
aura un autre tir c'est demain pierrette
brès fille avant de vous en parler
cuisine je voudrais vous rappeler que
demain c'est nous offre un programme de
qualité avec tout d'abord le prix de
l'ile-de-france qui sent un véritable
match entre les deux champions du trot
monté
kaiser trop et hissera qui ensuite le
prix de croix qui lui réunit les
meilleurs trotteurs de 5 ans comme par
exemple lançons l'agent et la gat et
enfin le tiercé qui aura lieu lui dans
une course beaucoup plus modeste
consacré aux trotteurs de 7 ans alors il
s'agit du prix de r s'il y une épreuve
au trot attelé longue de 2600 mètres
j'ai évité de placer les favoris en tête
de ce pronostic lorsque je les ai étudié
car dans cette course très ouverte
nombreux seront les concurrents capables
de défier d'enlever ce prix de 180 mille
francs offerts aux gagnants josas sera
donc mon cheval de base il aurait dû
gagner lors de sa dernière course mais
il a été gêné
pour lui ce sera l'occasion de se
racheter demain c'est un gysi qui lui
aussi a joué de malchance il a été
distancé injustement selon son dériveur
henry cogner j'ai dit à possède l'une
des premières chances dans cette course
jaguar du loir trouve ici un engagement
tout à fait à son niveau comme jolie
périgord d'ailleurs et puis gernot si le
cheval de classe de ce tiercé mais enfin
il reste sur deux échecs il faudra
qu'ils prouvent mieux demain et puis
jade rond et jolie gosses serons les
outsiders voilà essayer de bien noter
leur numéro 11 de 13 16 18 17 20 5 et 9
cette fois ci ce sont tous des noms en j
oui parce que ça ne donne l'âge des
trotteurs je vois non la lune n'est pas
au rendez vous ce soir ou plutôt ils se
cachent images du jour c'est en effet
elle éclipse de la lune qui a lieu en ce
moment d'un supposé qu'on la voit
philippe dumez et donc c'est une
malheureusement il fait vraiment trop
mauvais au dessus de paris pour qu'on
puisse voir quoi que ce soit et pourtant
c'est bien dommage parce qu'une éclipse
de lune c'est toujours un spectacle un
peu extraordinaire en effet la lune
n'est jamais totalement noir les rayons
du soleil où certains d'entre eux en
tout cas les rouges se réfracte sur
l'atmosphère de la terre et donne à
notre lune notre satellite
une couleur ocre un peu étrange il faut
tout de même savoir que c'est lors d'une
éclipse de lune comme celle ci
malheureusement on ne la voit pas ce
soir que les grecs il y a cinq siècles
avant jésus-christ ont réussi à
déterminer que la terre était ronde
cela leur a permis également de
déterminer avec une certaine précision
la distance entre la terre et la lune
malheureusement nous ne verrons pas ce
spectacle ce soir et laurent broomhead
nous dira peut-être pourquoi oui alors
pourquoi la lune est toujours là pour le
type il se trompe pas elle se produit et
je pense qu'elle est visible dans cette
région en particulier dans le midi et
peut-être même dans l'extrême nord
de l'europe et de la france où ma foi le
soleil est en train de revenir avec des
éclaircies qui feront d'ailleurs chuter
les températures pendant cette nuit ceci
dit le temps de demain bien c'est simple
froid neige et verglas au nord douceur
dans le sud du pays j'ai tout dit me
diriger vers la carte pour constater
qu'effectivement la france est coupée en
deux voies si cette carte on va
l'analyser donc une barrière ici du coup
en deux vous voilà avec ici une grande
bande de nuages des nuages qui donneront
des pluies verglaçantes et ensuite de la
neige demain nombre autour du verre de
la c'est important après la douceur
d'aujourd'hui la région parisienne et au
sud région de la loire retour du froid
et du verglas dans toutes ses routes
plus au nord demain retour du soleil
avec l'anticyclone avec un temps plus
sec mais également plus froids des jeux
les plus importantes toute la journée
moity sud celle inverse beaucoup de
nuages un temps doux avec des brumes le
matin mais également des éclaircies
toutefois regarder symbole de pluie ce
sont les nuages qui arriveront dans la
journée du côté de l'atlantique qui
progresseront vers le golfe du lion donc
à nouveau des pluies dans le sud-ouest
des du pays les températures pour demain
vous allez voir cette très nette
on est à nouveau coupée en 2 - 5 - 2 à
lille entre le matin et l'après-midi -
troyes - un appareil tonique aussi bien
à brest qu'à limoges les températures
seront moyenne en attendant le retour du
froid par la suite lundi est
particulièrement douce à toulouse et
marseille avec jusqu'à 15 degrés
l'après-midi pendant vos que vous
consultez l'agenda et que je souhaite
une bonne fête aux guillaume je vous
dirais que lundi le franc continuera sa
progression vers le sud
n'épargnant que la région
méditerranéenne et l'extrême midi où là
il y aura en revanche des nuages et de
la pluie mais à l'âge le pitre et nous
en dira plus
à 23h votre dernier journal avec bernard
pradines oh et puis un petit cadeau pour
terminer ce journal pour vous consoler
de ne pas passer votre soirée avec
michel drucker aux champs elysées vous
savez que son émission a été ajourné en
raison d'une grève de la sfp
dans cette émission que vous verrez donc
samedi prochain legault police ce groupe
britannique dont les disques bat tous
les records de vente et qui donnera deux
concerts au bourget demain et après
demain
le groupe police donc grâce à michel
drucker la sfp et gérard holtz je vous
dis bon soir en musique à demain 20
heures
explique sans faille au stade de france
un peu pas très bien assez pour acheter
de hamburgers ah non moi par les
français honni soit qui mal y pense
le groupe police qui inaugure donc la
saison de rock'n'roll à paris avec une
capitale paris qui est devenue la grande
ville du rock'n'roll à travers le monde
au cours de ces dernières années en
effet lorsqu'on fait le bilan on
s'aperçoit que toutes les grandes
popstars c'est à dire toutes les grandes
vedettes du rock n roll sont venus
chanter à paris au cours de ces derniers
mois il ya eu bob dylan il ya eu bob
marley il y a eu le groupe ac dc il y a
même eu il ya deux ans un peu plus de
deux ans même les rolling stones
bref paris capitale mondiale du rock n
roll avec un paradoxe tout de même paris
n'a pas de très grandes salles de
spectacle
hippodrome de la porte de pantin ne fait
que 7000 places le palais des sports
5000 l'olympia 2000 alors le groupe
police a choisi la retourne du bourget
une très grande salle à la périphérie de
paris à sept kilomètres exactement de la
porte de la chapelle pour se produire
c'est en effet l'une des seules salles
qui dans la banlieue parisienne peut
accueillir quinze mille spectateurs